welcome to the Royal Institution of for
tonight's exciting debate on whether
pornography is good for us my name is
Vivek Roscoe and I'm going to be
chairing tonight's debate
so our motion for tonight is porn is
good for us without it we would be a
more repressed Society so with that in
mind let us say hooray for porn where
would we be without it bored repressed
frustrated porn lights up the lives of
the depressed the lonely and the
sexually uninvent URIs it spices up dull
marriages it brings excitement to
relationships it tells us where to look
and where to touch on the other hand is
poor land really such a nice place to be
far from nailing a lie isn't porn
selling a lie that women are always
eager and willing to engage in extreme
practices that bodies are always tanned
and buffed breasts always pert orgasms
always explosive and to attract the
restless for internet porn in particular
is having to up the ante cyber sex is
getting ever harsher and more degrading
more extreme what kind of a warped
desensitized view of human intimacy does
this offer up to our children so great
liberator of the libido or a blight on
our intimate lives tonight we'll hear
from a pornographic filmmaker a renowned
addiction therapist and two academic
experts on both sides of the oral
argument and but first of all I'd like
to explain a procedure for tonight on
the way in you will have all voted using
one of these voting slips and when we've
heard from all of the speakers we'll be
announcing the results of that vote so
that we know what the feelings of the
audience are when when you were coming
into the room then so before then we'll
be hearing from each of the speakers who
each have nine minutes to plead their
cause for and against then we'll hear
the pre vote and then we'll take some
questions from the audience so that we
can
and see how your feelings are on this
subject and you'll have a chance to quiz
the panel will then be asking you to
vote again
so after questions have been taken from
the floor ashes will be going around and
asking you to pick these up and if you
don't know don't touch your card so
leave your two card untouched for now
and then you just rip it to vote for or
against and then we all have closing
remarks of two minutes from each of the
speakers and then we'll reveal the final
vote so that we can know how your minds
have been changed because this motion
really is for you to decide so let me
then welcome our first speaker for the
motion
she's a pornographic film director who
works under the pseudonym Anna span
she runs a campaign site for erotic
workers called www-we Consent org which
campaigns against moral panics and anti
erotic industry legislation please
welcome to the podium Anna Aerosmith
[Applause]
can you hear me okay yeah cool at 16 I
was a self-proclaimed feminist who
believed what mainstream feminists and
politicians like Claire Short was saying
that porn degraded women however one day
I was walking down old Compton Street in
London's red lights district and I
realized that my anger was actually envy
I was envious of men having their
sexuality catered for in so many
different ways from prostitution
magazines to films in the late 1980s
women's sexuality was not catered for at
all I knew then that it was far more
productive and feminist to invest my
time in creating something that allowed
women to explore their sexuality than it
was to thwart men's freedoms sexual
objectification that is fleetingly
seeing somebody for their sexually
attractiveness alone is something women
do just as easily as men it just isn't
seen as socially acceptable for women I
now work as part of a burgeoning
feminist and queer porn industry which
is changing perceptions of sex on film
during my first degree Irish shock the
can whose work tells us that whatever
gives you pleasure gives you power this
throws the traditional model of vertical
power into question therefore whatever
interests you sexually is what you
should practice law willing so if you're
sexually submissive you are disempowered
if you do not admit this to yourself as
you deny yourself access to pleasure so
understand pornography is important to
understand this point pornography is not
the acting out of politics pornography
is the acting out of the imagination and
role play which is only in part
influenced by the wider gender arena it
is more useful to liken pawn to a game
or a sport than it is to everyday life
porn stars and directors get power from
expanding their limitations of their
imaginations and bodily experiences
anti-porn feminists make mistake extreme
sex with a lack of consent that is they
compare sex with the rest of social life
imagine for a moment a thought
experiment in 1980 a prominent theorist
on the subjects of violence links
professional boxing to street and
domestic violence he argues that men are
watching boxing on the television and
acting out what they see on the streets
after all it follows that these men want
to be seen as similar to their boxing
idols in response to this concern it is
easy to argue that televised
professional boxing adheres to certain
legal and cultural rules which render it
different from everyday violence we
watch boxing as violence in quotation
marks it's a sport not real life people
still know it is wrong to physically
attack someone in reality even though
they enjoy it as entertainments
unfortunately for pornography such a
theorist did exist Andrea Dworkin wrote
that pornography led to rape and the
retardation of women's equality in the
workplace and home even though extensive
research into pornography and its
negative effects has only ever presented
highly inconclusive findings
ever since talking we have been almost
nura linguistically programs to link
porn with rape because it's such an
emotive issue and therefore a difficult
link to shake such theorists see women
as inevitable victims which in turn
encourage women to see themselves as
victims
it is this anti porn feminism that gave
men the power to taunt women with porn
in offices and private lives as at all
which is mistakenly seen a shorthand for
female disempowerment this is not to say
that there is no inequality in the porn
industry
it is certainly the case that women are
encouraged to play submissive roles in
some films but when people argue that
the worst thing about porn is women are
seen to be enjoying being raped or being
abused they effectively say that
regardless of how much autonomy
education or will of personality a woman
has she cannot consent to being in or
consuming pawn or therefore to being an
SI porn either it's worth remembering at
this point that independent research
shows that 30 percent of all online porn
is consumed by women the anti-porn
position is not based on expanding
women's rights
it's a thinly veiled conservative and
religious argument that firmly keeps
women within the [ __ ] madonna dichotomy
that most feminists and women have been
fighting to escape for decades there is
not a campaign to save women and
children there's as a fully-fledged
moral panic as per Stanley Cohen's
influential book folk devil's and moral
panics
using his theory the forum porn
producers have been chosen as a soft
target for moral entrepreneurs those who
stand to gain the most from the panic in
order to protect a whole host of
society's ills onto one identifiable
culprit that should be eliminated in
order to magically deliver gender
equality in this instance we've been
here before in 1984 with a video
recordings act when Mary Whitehouse
stated that nearly 40% of all
six-year-olds watch video nasties
journalists who found six-year-olds
admitting to seeing films that did not
exist easily refuted this but now
children are seen as victims in pawn
especially girls who are apparently
helpless in the face of sexual ization
with no libido of their own but do the
facts support this concern well in a new
book becoming sexual dr. Daniel Egan
refutes all the common arguments for
instance in the United Kingdom America
and Australia it has been found that
girls are waiting longer to lose their
virginity than ever before pregnancy
rates have dropped to an the lowest rate
in 30 years overwhelmingly girls are
experiencing their first sexual
experience with a steady partner and are
using contraception as a condoms for the
first time of an intercourse by far the
most frequent sexual experience for
young people is self masturbation not
boys receiving oral sex as is often
claimed sexual abuse and physical abuse
of children has significantly declined
adolescent crime rates have also dropped
as part of a trend that shows a 49
percent drop in all violent crime since
1995 in the UK more girls are normal
weight or overweight than under weights
and higher rates of women at age 18 as
well as later in life are undertaking
further and higher education than men as
readers of Foucault will know we have
been panicking about children and
sexuality since the early 1800s when
boys masturbation was a focus then in
the 20th century it was teenage
pregnancy now sexual ization but this
debate is focused on wipe all the porn
industry is good for society so allow me
to give you a few good reasons Paul
keeps couples together it's common for
one couple to have a higher sex one
member of a couple have a higher sex
drive than the other usually
and pornography is one way for such
people to sate their desires without
resorting to breaking up the
relationship having affairs paying for
sex or pestering their partners for sex
unlike most mainstream TV and film porn
a pornography actually democratizes the
body there is a market for literally
anything as it is 50% of the industry is
amateur showing all types of physiques
although this is not showing when the
industry is represented through the
mainstream media that constantly
promotes the pneumatic blonde stereotype
even though a recent longitudinal study
showed that the average female porn star
is 23 year-old brunette with a b-cup I
often say to women who don't like
something about themselves for instance
body hair or body size stick it into a
search engine and add the word porn next
to it and you will find a whole host of
sites that think is them this is the
most attractive thing about you ponder
Moulton democratizes sex acts to making
sexual acts less shameful in society
women used to be blamed for anything
that was not entirely vanilla now it's
more about personal taste the Pro and
anti porn industries pays the wages of
hundreds of thousands of taxpayers
pornography continually develops and
popularizes new technology which we all
owe a debt for pornography is a good
vehicle for learning about the human
body in the absence of decent sexual
education it is where most men learn
where the clitoris a spot and G spots
are the porn industry is organized
around the women who perform in the
films as they decide their limits and
are hired on that basis it's the only
industry I know where a woman's period
is a good reason to change a shoot date
to suit being a mother or indeed being
pregnant simply means you sell to a new
and different market
compare this to the banking industry
where women have to ignore their female
traits and bodies in order to get on
duty pawns popularizing of shaved pubic
hair which was always about relaxed
censorship laws in the USA in the 1990s
due to the Clintons interestingly with
both men and women shaving not about the
model's age as has been argued
after all a 20 year old model with
shaved pubes looks like a 20 year old
model with shaved pubes not a 10 year
old at least one Health Authority in the
northeast of England has eliminated
pubic lice in its entire population plus
we no longer need to suffer pubes at the
back of the throat
we all have pawned to thank for that a
final positive I would argue is from my
own perspective Paul has been a hugely
positive and exciting industry to work
in that has expanded my knowledge of sex
and human interaction immensely one day
I will be filming a buxom no nonsan
nurse with their unwitting male patients
and the next I'll be filming policemen
and women in full gear going at it
hammer and tongs what can be wrong with
that
my conclusion it is important to be
aware of moral panics especially around
the emotive subjects of sexuality which
is always going to be exciting on some
level please don't vote for an argument
that says the world is going to hell in
the handcart it isn't the world is just
a complicated place in which civil
liberties must be maintained and
democracy respected thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much Anna Aerosmith if I
could just take a moment to remind you
that you are welcome to tweet during
this debate using the hashtag iq2 porn
perhaps restrain yourselves from using
your phones to use the search engine as
Anna suggests dared perhaps you could do
that afterwards so let us welcome now
our first speaker against the motion
he's a leading expert on the treatment
of addictive and compulsive behavior
he's the founder of the UK's first
addiction treatment center and has
worked with over 5,000 inpatients and
many more outpatients from his South
Kensington office patients suffering
from a variety of difficulties including
addiction to sex and pornography in 2009
he retired as GP in order to focus on
his addiction work please welcome to the
podium dr. Robert Lefevre
[Music]
politically I'm a libertarian I don't
like rules and regulations affecting
individuals there are two caveats the
first is where it affects other people
if my freedom impinges on yours that's
wrong and the second is rather more
tricky and that's where the person may
not be competent to decide what is good
or bad and the obvious example of that
is pornography with young children the
child is too young to make an adult
decision an awareness of what's
happening but in my particular field I
was a member of the board of the
libertarian Alliance but I resign from
it because I recognize that with
addiction there's no Liberty we're
trapped in our addiction it's not a
lifestyle choice it's a compulsive
behavior consequently it's very
important for us to be able to define
what addiction really is because this is
not a small problem overall it's
estimated there's something between ten
and fifteen percent of the population
have addiction problems as with alcohol
or drugs or food or nicotine or gambling
or whatever so this means that each GP
with an average list of 2300 patients
will have something in the order of
three hundred addicts to look after and
if the experience of today's medical
students was any different from mine I
had not one single lesson in six years
on addiction and incidentally as a GP I
had not one lesson on counseling either
so we're putting doctors into the front
line to look after massive numbers of
people with with an addiction an average
GP will see four new cancers a year
we'll see one case of Crohn's disease
every six years we'll see one case of a
pheochromocytoma every 200 years but
we'll have 300 addicts we're doing work
that we're not trained to do or we have
no understanding on
so there's something very strange in
medical education which is where I put
the blame but well those of us who have
addiction problems are concerned it's
more personally significant we're
compelled we just don't know how to get
out of it
or stop drinking I tried well try harder
I did well do what I do I can't you know
there's no understanding at the trap
that addicts are in therefore it's vital
for us to be able to define addiction
and to see who it is who has the most
likely problem because if the problem is
as widespread as that then we must be
able to really look at it and help
people with the problem as far as sex
and love addiction is concerned
Patrick Karns is the international
expert on the subject and he estimates
that the the incidence of sex and sex
addiction is about 6% of the population
that 6% are using sex for addictive
purposes rather than for pleasure or for
happiness or fulfillment I've worked
with Patrick Karzai I spent a week with
him and I very much admire him as
someone who's really trying to talk
about difficult subject what he says is
that in sex addiction the incidence is
about 3 men to 1 women one woman but the
the incidence in women is rising largely
because of the internet where the access
is anonymous and so there are more women
becoming sex addicts nowadays than
previously there are 12 addictive
characteristics which I won't go through
now if you're in certain you can look
them up on my website but these
characteristics will define who is an
addict and who is not I saw a patient
earlier today who had absolutely not one
ounce of addiction and I thought well
how old
because I'm not like that I'm full of it
I'm riddled with addiction but I don't
do addictive things nowadays you know
it's a choice in terms of behavior that
I can do now that is constructive
whereas previous behavior that I did
that was very destructive as far as
these sex and love addiction is
concerned what's that Patrick Ganz has
pointed out is that we really need to
recognize that all addiction is
progressive and destructive there's no
little bit of addiction it's all
progressive and destructive is just a
matter of when
but we shouldn't penalize everybody just
because of the behavior of some people
this is what governments do they have
health warnings on everything well the
health warnings meant no no interest to
me
whatever Ann Eden I'm a doctor I was
smoking 30 cigarettes a day when I was
looking after patients on the Hart ward
you know I'm an addict that's just the
way I am thank God I was never a sex and
love addict so that didn't happen but
people would say to me people would say
to me sometimes I wouldn't mind a bit of
that car like I said no yeah really
don't know the suicide rate of people
with sex and love addiction it is
significant it's very high in suicide
rate and you can see why it's because
people destroy their own personal
relationships if their sex and I've had
AIDS and the typical example is like
some sex tear no thanks
what am i lying down well I have some no
that is not a close relationship that's
using somebody as a drug oh that's very
destructive and ultimately you finish up
with a lot of very lonely own people so
what we need to do is to find a way of
identifying these people as I said on my
website you can see how that can be done
but the government still comes out with
all these regulations all these pious
hopes that they can show wonderful
examples of how moral behavior is going
to change the world now that's not what
it's about
we need to identify those specific
individuals who have an addiction
problem and treat them appropriately
then the
the population didn't get on and do what
they want provided as I said that is not
damaging other people and that people
who are doing something are competent to
make adult decisions a DS will only
change our behavior when we're in pain I
was 47 years old when I got into
recovery from my addiction for some he
could have been diagnosed when I was
seven now that's wrong
the lack of understanding of what
addiction really is is to blame medical
schools are to blame the legalization or
illegal ization of various addictive
behaviors drugs and so on it's a
necessary part believe it or not of
Liberty because only that way two people
accumulate sufficient pain to say our
[ __ ] I think I may need to change my
behavior so it's odd that here's me as a
libertarian saying that we should keep
some things illegal because I'm using it
as a medical intervention and say only
when you've done this and that and the
other and all the rest of it I've got
yourself into real pain will you
eventually face up to the fact you need
to change your behavior otherwise you're
going to be in big trouble just before I
came here I was dealing with a mother
over a young man who's actually not that
young he's 40 but four is well compared
to some of us he's getting into a lot of
trouble and what we going to do for him
nothing why not because he's below the
radar he's in work he's earning a living
he's got a car in the garage she's got
her own restaurant it's not going to
help him he needs confrontation as a GP
in central London I had my own private
laboratory so I've looked after a lot of
sex workers of swingers of sex addicts
my favorite sex worker was a child
psychologist
I thought she had ideal training for the
work that she did she was great
I have a lot of time for these people
because I'm a doctor damn it I don't
make moral judgments on other people's
behavior
however as an individual I was married
for forty eight and a half years until
my wife died of a stroke that was wrong
I'm tired again now and my wife patches
just here and I hope that we'll hit the
tongue for at least a half century and
get to our golden wedding anniversary
I'll be 125 she will be 72 123 but why
not
why not we're young what I'm saying is
we're happy and I believe a major part
of that as a pornography has played no
part in my life and there's addictive
substances and processes no longer play
a part at all this is the happiness that
I want to share with other people thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much dr. Robert Lefevre
so week waiting some of your advice to
my husband later on our second speaker
for the motion is reader in sexualities
and culture at the University of
Sunderland her research focuses on the
everyday uses of pornography and how
people who use it feel that it fits into
their lives she's the author of the
first large-scale study of audiences
engaging with sexual media and is
currently writing up the results of a
survey of more than 5,000 respondents
she's the co-editor of the academic
quarterly journal porn studies please
welcome to the podium dr. Clarissa Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thanks for the introduction as
well so my unlike Roberts I have had
quite a long history of looking at
pornography and I've done it for 20
years as part of my professional
practice I have a bit of a problem with
the debate question as set pornography
is good for us without it we would be a
far more repressed society I don't I
don't have a problem with this trying to
talk about what might be the best ways
to understand sexually explicit media
but I do have a problem with the idea
that there is a singular thing that we
can discuss as pornography and that we
can decide on the basis of that
discussion whether it's good or bad for
us my reasons for that are that first
there is no singular porn industry we
constantly find it talked in those ways
in academic circles in the media by
politicians as if there actually exists
a singular entity there is no one porn
industry there are industries and some
of them look much more like your sole
trader artist than they do a big-budget
studio what of course those singular is
a shion's of porn are attempting to do
is to
the industry by its sheer size it gets
talked about as an undifferentiated mass
of greed and that it's products all head
in the same direction it's hard to think
of any other industry that gets treated
in that way that is condemned just
because of its success and we ought to
actually to acknowledge that it's it's a
presumed success because in fact most of
the numbers that we have are really
rather shaky we can't be sure they are
estimates but estimates place the value
of the porn industry in the USA at 8
billion and globally at 13 billion now
that sounds significant doesn't it
except that the USA fast food sector has
a value of over 110 billion per year the
largest grossing film of all time
avatar gross 2.7 billion on its own and
Hollywood's global profit exceeds a
hundred million Hollywood alone ok its
global profit exceeds a hundred billion
per year so we are not talking about an
industry that like some juggernaut comes
rolling into town and squashes
everything in front of it there are big
studios and there are sole operators
there are lots of different kinds of
pornography too there are some who would
claim that porn has no generic elements
to it that it's not it doesn't have its
own representational vocabularies that
it has no narratives it has no art and
I'd say after 20 years of looking at
this stuff that they're talking out
their hearts there are varieties of
pornography from the most obvious a
mature alt queer straight those based on
practices orientations or styles of body
but also diversification and modes of
distribution the free sites online
shared community spaces magazines
because believe it or not actually some
people still prefer to get their sexy
times from a magazine and actually there
are still those people who prefer to
find it accidentally in bushes and in
parks and stuff the porn fairies
deliveries are still looked for by some
people and then there are DVDs
and there are other kinds of productions
too and in DVDs we've got huge
production numbers like Michael NIN's
the four or punky vignettes like Jack
the zippers black light Beauty G's least
genderqueer gender [ __ ] alternative porn
there's [ __ ] for forest ethical porn
miss naughties porn for women we could
also mention that Anna's work clown porn
furry porn parody porn there are all
kinds of pornography's out there and
they have their own imperatives and you
all have noticed actually that I haven't
actually divided that up into sexual
orientations there and we could do that
too and people make choices about the
porn they view they take the effort to
seek out the materials they like
pornography is meaningful to them and
what is always central to me in the
various debates about pornography and
its role is that so many claims are made
about the people who choose to view it
who consume it porn consumers tend to be
represented as deviant slightly suspect
and probably addicted that comes from an
Australian piece of research at porn
port Michael Lee he they evangelist and
author of porn nation has claimed that
porn is America's number one addiction
I'm writing for psychologies magazine
British journalist eka Aiken head as
described boys sitting in silence
staring at hardcore pornography in the
playground and swapping unbelievable
images of astonishing sexual violence as
if they were pokemon cards along with
this we have the Australian parenting
author Steve bit off who claims that
porn is responsible for one of the most
depressed anxious and lonely generations
of young people ever to inhabit the
earth I find it quite interesting that
we're in this room a place where medical
issues being discussed for a couple of
centuries and there are very clear
parallels here with this discuss that a
discourse of porn addiction and porn
problems with the 19th century
masturbation debates okay and and
actually very clear ones sunken eyed
children who spoke in their bedrooms and
refused to speak to their parents
that seems to be most teenagers behavior
anywhere what's the problem with that so
none of these claims are actually based
on evidence and the consumption of
pornography remains a huge gap in our
knowledge we know less about the
audiences of pornography than probably
any other genre of popular entertainment
and as the introduction said my own
research has tried to get at people's
everyday engagements with porn and how
they do that and why they do that on how
it fits into their lives how it makes a
difference to them and most recently
that has been through this project that
we launched online at porn research org
and to which we got [ __ ] more than
five and a half thousand responses the
picture that emerges from that research
is seriously at odds with the most
familiar representations of pornography
audiences one of the main motives for us
in completing that research I did it
with two colleagues Fiona Atwood and
Martin Barker both of whom are very
respected in in the areas of taboo media
one of them main motives for our
research Wizard pawn research has been
completely dominated by artificial and
highly judgmental ways of investigating
and that they simply won't ask ordinary
people would they enjoy about porn it's
been very instructive in the last five
years to take part in policy debates
where everybody talks about pornography
and claims never to have looked at it
themselves but knows exactly what it is
that every user is doing with it and to
know best what would be the thing to do
with them - right so there are real
problems with this this that kind of
research that kind of talk judges from
afar and effectively presumes consumers
to be incompetent and damaged okay so
our respondents were incredibly open
with us they're fantastically generous
with their time they told us about their
histories and their lives and what comes
out of that is a porn is an important
leisure activity for many people and it
is representative of wider changing
attitudes to sex relationships identity
body and the place of technologies in
intimate life country to the press
stories which talk of young people as
exposed to the harms of pornography
young people who spoke to us talked
about themselves as having histories
experience and using porn to think about
themselves and their real or potential
partners in order to come to terms with
their own bodily responses to things
sexual older respondents talked about
porn as a means of accessing bodily
sensations which which may express forms
of nostalgia and attempts to get back to
previous kinds of intimacy porn is not a
special case to be thought of separately
from other forms of production or
consumption and it's not in a singular
form with singular purposes and/or
effects there are complex relations
between representation reality and
fantasy and that's one of the most
important things that's coming out of
our research is what does fantasy mean
to people these complexities of the
relations between the self in the worlds
of imagination require more than
scaremongering like all forms of
cultural production pawn contributes has
contributed to our sense of
possibilities personal and individual
possibilities and that is surely one of
the ways in which we are less repressed
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you doctor Clarissa Smith I was
just thinking it must surely be the only
time in the Royal Institution that furry
porn has been referenced or perhaps not
finally our second speaker against the
motion she's a feminist author academic
and broadcaster described as the major
feminist voice of the 20th century her
ideas have created controversy ever
since her book the Female Eunuch became
a best-seller in 1970
she's now special fellow over noon and
column Cambridge please welcome
professor Germaine Greer
[Applause]
[Music]
I suppose I also confess that I have
been a pornographer completely failed
wanted to replace the agenda of screw
with a non sadistic agenda of suck we
produced seven numbers I think of our
magazine in Amsterdam and as a way of
changing its sadistic exploitation of
young people who posed willingly for us
naked I suggested that all of us ugly
old editors should be photographed naked
the only one of us who had any kind of
public profile was me so I had to think
hard about how to do the photograph and
I had to make sure that it couldn't be
ripped off by the commercial soft porn
industry so I had already explained to
playboy who offered me a gatefold
that I would do it if I could stand with
my back to the camera and look at the
lens through my knees it took them a
while to figure that out because as
usual had forgotten that women have
anuses you might have noticed that and
so they said they thought they weren't
ready for that but suck was ready for
that and I did do it unfortunately you
can't change the iron reality of what is
as has been explained a business
my fellow editors used the picture as
page three they blew it up to the full
broadsheet size they cut a signature off
one of my letters pasted it on the
bottom as if it was a piece of
gratuitous exhibitionism on my part and
they were never photographed themselves
what I was trying to do then was to
change pornography I was trying to make
it not sadistic I don't know that we can
do this until we liberate human
sexuality most of its
pression will be sadistic and commercial
porn is no different it's predicated on
prion penetration whether the
penetration is of women men or animals
or children the person who is penetrated
is degraded by the interaction until we
actually change our own sexual culture
we can't change that we can't change
that by pretending that it's been
changed the motion in my view is upside
down
pornography doesn't make us less
repressed pornography is a way of making
money out of the fact that we are
repressed not for nothing is the [ __ ]
shot
known as the money shot pornography we
get confused when we talk about it as a
style or a genre I'm in favor of erotic
art I hope desperate to find a way to
reincorporate sexuality in the narrative
that we give of our lives and it's
virtually impossible because for some
reason it gets hived off into this
special realm pornography is not a style
or a genre it's a business the target
customer regardless of whether the
depicted act involves women men children
or animals is male the need for
pornography arises from our sexual
incapacity now I'm not going to do a men
are from Mars and women are from Venus
number here but we have a problem of
misunderstanding each other and having
sexualities that are not symmetrical
pornography perpetuates the stereotypic
notion of sexual intercourse as
essentially penetrative the penis is
rock-hard even though in most of the
porn films I've seen and I wasn't judged
at the wet dream Film Festival in
Amsterdam in 1972 in most of the films
I've been made to watch the penis is
distinctly rubbery
now that we have video hard disk video
cameras that can record seven hours
without changing the mag maybe it's not
as rubbery as it used to be maybe we can
actually stay with it till we get to the
money shot but the other problem is that
the behavior of the female usually in
these interactions has been laid down
God knows when I've also been a judge of
video discs made by celebrities in which
practically every woman made the little
animal cries they'd say your [ __ ] is
giving me as much pleasure as it's
giving you which is a lie
quite the most tragic of these fairly
tragic items was the one made by the
very successful woman now known as Katie
Price
where's quite the saddest porn video I
think I've ever seen now if we're
talking about how people learn how to
take care of each other one of the big
problems with the porn that teenagers
are watching is it doesn't give any
importance to the condom it doesn't
bring it into the interaction a bigger
probably because it's practically
impossible we pretend that everything's
going fine because we don't know how
often the morning-after pill is required
we don't know how many of our young
women are having unprotected sex we know
they all think it's a long-term partner
and we know that they're nearly always
wrong but even subtler than that is the
fact that pornography fetishizes the
body now it may be great to be told look
you're an amputee put in amputee plus
pawn and you'll discover there's there's
a bunch of people out there who get off
on your stump that isn't going to be
frightfully good news what you're hoping
is that they get off on you you don't
want to be told that you now have become
a subclass of a fetish likewise you've
got one breast three times bigger than
the other you really want someone to
make love to you for that reason women
always believe it's love they always
rely on words one of the things about
pornography is that it's mostly
speechless
the thing you remember is not what was
done but what was said
pornography postulates limitless male
potency which can't be arrived at in the
real world but the really sinister thing
about it is that it makes sex easy it is
the psychological equivalent of
convenience food it provides easy
ready-made fantasy to be used in the
mechanical relief of sexual tension the
relief is superficial masturbation is
like housework it's only to be done
again
repetitive meaningless like convenience
food
you stuffed food in your mouth whenever
you think you might want it but it
doesn't satisfy you were never replete
you are never hungry real encounters
carry with them the possibility of
rejection of humiliation are being
deceived exploited of being impotent
they are adventures sex is a bloodsport
we approach each other with trepidation
as intimacy intensifies the possibility
of hurt becomes greater
we are encountered jealousy the most
debilitating illness of all pornography
is your paper doll the gal that other
fellows cannot steal pornography won't
betray you
it won't dump you sex is as difficult as
conversation whether there's greater
propensity for going wrong pornography
replaces the uncertainty of real
encounters with real people with
stereotypical fantasy relief of tension
is assured
but ecstasy is out of reach out of sight
unimaginable passion is a concept
emptied of significance commitment is
not an issue the sexual revolution
didn't liberate sex it liberated
pornography ready-made sexual fantasy
appeared on every book stand a huge
industry developed much huger I think
than we realize pornography is part of
the marketing of prostitution and it
bleeds back into real life reality
becomes an unpleasant surprise
little girls are trying to assuage the
anxieties of their young boyfriends
they're desperate to have a full
Brazilian age 13 we need not commercial
pornography which exists to suck the
money out of pockets of men but an
integration of carnality in the
narrative of daily life we need to
rediscover or maybe reinvent intimacy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much professor
jamaandgraham now before I sit down then
we open questions to the floor I just
like to reveal the results of the
prevail
so before the debate as you were all
coming in the results are for the motion
45 percent against the motion 22% and
don't know 33% so with that in mind and
please do raise your hand if you'd like
to ask a question it would be great if
you could very briefly say your name and
say whether you're for or against the
motion or undecided and if we could just
have very brief to the point questions
that would be fantastic lovely yes sir
I'm interested in the comments that have
been made about the commercial side of
pornography I had occasion to do some
investigations around an area I'd moved
into and I found a lot of commercial
sites that were designed to tell
everybody that every single village in
the county where I live Essex has got
sheds full of swingers all at it it was
hilarious because certainly in the
particular village I live in life is
deadly dull in that particular respect I
I have a background involving farming
and artificial insemination in animals
and persuading male animals to do
unnatural things in order that we can
have cheaper food I've also written
about boys who've been abandoned by
fathers thank you so can we take your
name and whether you're for or against
the motion I am against the motion
my name is Peter ensign ons Owen thank
you well just wrap up quickly yeah I'd
be interested to to hear more about this
commercial push because I don't
understand why people have to be told
what they want and what they might like
okay Thank You organizations thank you
I'll take a question from this lady over
here I'm against the motion
I just wonder my question is how do we
do it practically when we look at
democracy that's quite funny isn't it
it's great thank you yes so your
question is really about legislation
yeah great thank you one more from up
here and then we'll come to the panel
hello my name is Matthew garner I'm in
favor of the motion a brief comments
mostly focusing on what our final
speaker professor Greer had to say the
concluding remark he made was in
connection with rediscovering a range of
carnality and and sexual expression and
a kind of a more democratic and perhaps
less oppressive in your view view of
human expression of sexuality I can't
help feeling that perhaps you may be a
little out of date in regard to what is
actually out there in the world of
pornography these days I believe the
other speakers in favor of the motion
highlights the fact that there is a huge
range of amateur pornography there is a
huge drive amongst certain sectors of
the population to record and to
celebrate their sexuality and if you are
looking at what pornography actually
exists then you'll find that it isn't
just this I'm afraid I don't really
recognize this notion that you have of
the subjugation of women as a default
focus on penis vagina sex the idea that
women are inherently and always degraded
and and submissive in this I just don't
think you're up to date on that that's
great thank you very much I'm picking up
on Peter's point I'd like to put this to
Anna
aerosmith and as professor Germaine
Greer said pornography is a way of
making money as the fact that we are
repressed so could you say something in
response to the question about
commercialism well actually I think the
thing is that porn is actually parts as
you mentioned swinging but I was going
to be use a metaphor and say vehicular
sex as well also I just say dogging I
mean it's happening you know everywhere
it's porn is just part of what I would
call a sort of silent sexual revolution
that's going on and I would disagree
with Jemaine saying that it didn't free
people I think you know it didn't free
people equally but we have found
especially in the last 10 to 15 years
women are getting I mean swinging if you
look at the industry is really well if
you call it an industry is really run by
a female desire to to sort of meet other
men and so I actually think that porn is
just part of that and a lot of it isn't
for money
I mean you know people aren't making
money out of dogging and just reacted
okay to you people are not people are
not making money out of this it's not
about money difficulty is and we said
something about this before the
difficulty is about the definition
dogging is not pornography being
involved in actual sexual activity is
not pornography
pornos prostitute graphics or however it
goes in greek i right we've got to be
sure what this is I mean that's why I
chose it's not sexual activity that's
not what we're talking about we're
talking about the creation of a kind of
literature film etc etc always had one
removed that's what makes it safe going
with the prostitute involves you were
entering into her social media taking a
risk all kinds of risk she lives in a
very dangerous environment unless she's
a very fortunate kind of upper-class
expensive prostitute going there is one
kind of adventure
reading about it pretending seeing a
picture of her means that you can in
fantasy enter into that completely
non-committal arrangement without
running any personal risk now ultimately
we've got to be prepared to countenance
risk in personal relationships they're
risky things you get hurt you have to
persevere you have to understand
that this person can throw you right off
beam when you think you're getting
somewhere with her or him because of
something that is said or something that
is done or because of what's happened to
that person before sex is really
difficult and the problem with
pornography is it makes it seem easy I
wanted to pull back on on Tuesday the
points were made actually there's a lot
of assumptions here that the only kinds
of pornography that exist are
heterosexual that that's what we're
talking about and the fact is that
actually there's an awful lot porn out
there that speaks to sexual minorities
and does so in ways be precisely because
they are repressed and precisely because
they do need to be told that it is okay
to do things in in ways that are not
validated within the wider culture and
that's one of the ways in which actually
is very clear the porn has it may not be
responsible for our toleration our
understanding now of alternative
sexualities but it has certainly gone
hand in hand with that increasing
toleration and I think sometimes the
absolute literalness of the definition
of porn as the writing of [ __ ]
actually misses or prostitutes misses
absolutely what is going on in
pornography and the varieties of it and
the ways that it speaks to communities
and that's actually the point by the
doggin site or the swinging sites is
that it's about community and intimacy
within those communities if you're
outside it you don't understand it but
that doesn't mean to say you know
anything about those people and then we
should be clear that we are talking
about people whose life choices may not
be the same in south and there are no
less appropriate and good for all of
that and intimate and intimate and
carnal and all of those lovely things
that we might all want for ourselves
can I come to Lefevre for a response to
the question about legislation what can
we practically do probably nothing
[Music]
this is this is the great fallacy of
government they believe that there are
laws which will change society Society
changes itself in time and I don't think
that laws against pornography are going
to do anything else but just drive it
further underground or wherever I don't
think it will actually change human
behavior nobody has been in favor of
censorship of pornography or what we've
been doing is opposing the motion that
pornography is good for us lots of
things around that are not good for us
at all but they're not illegal and we
don't want to make pornography illegal
either because ironically I can remember
when it was illegal and you could pay an
awful lot of money for the most
disgusting postcards of of Asian
children being [ __ ] by black sailors
you could buy them in Soho for like 40
quid these dreadful things and that
would be my sort of snobbish thing about
most of the pornography I've been
privileged to see is that it's boring
its repetitive its dreary it there's
never any conversation you don't get
anywhere it's as boring as wanking okay
please say your name and whether you're
for or against the motion hi my name is
Marcus warrior I was initially
marginally against the motion by my
point first is that culture affects
attitudes towards different things they
wants to be in one country and is not to
do in another so for examples attitudes
towards sexuality between Scandinavia
and the UK have always been different
I've always been different this kind of
relates back to the point about
repressed Jemaine Gray's point about how
the porn industry is making money out of
the fact we were oppressed if if
referring back to my previous point if
wants to imply from that somehow in the
UK we're marginally more repressed that
brats other countries the question is
how do we get less repressed and in the
meantime given that it's quite a sort of
lofty perhaps long
goal in the meantime perhaps we enjoy a
little bit of porn that's not the end of
the world thank you yes this gentleman
in the in the black behind you please
thank you thank you I'm Daniel Dutton
and I'm mildly for the motion but
Germaine Greer was talking in a
discussion of photography was bringing
in pedophilia and best eality is some of
the more extreme forms but in fact you
know through through legislative
developments
I mean pornography has has largely
cleaned up its and I think that needs to
be brought into the discussion i don't
think if you look on the internet you
won't find a lot of best eality and
pedophilia in this country decent open
kind of site so I think the situation
has dramatically changed in that respect
and I think we need to pay attention to
that hey thank you and then Desmond in
front of you hmm
thank you I'm flooring the terrace and
I'm still undecided but I think it's
worthwhile noting that there's an a
documentary called life after
pornography that interviews five porno
people and looks at their lives and I
think all of them were quite destroyed
you know so just from the people that
participate actively in it I think
that's one perspective and then a
different perspective is the users in
common I think the doctor made a very
good distinction there between you know
normal and addictive people I don't know
I think we're all addictive in some some
shape or form the part I'm having
trouble with the debate is that without
it because it assumes that it is
possible in that leads right to
censorship or some form of doing a way
which I think we all agree that's not
it's not something doable so I think
that's the way I have a hard time making
up my mind because I think the question
has been framed with a dilemma built in
it which is that there's no without it
it's been around forever it's a human
need it's one of the fundamental human
needs sexuality and it's also worth
noting the incredible power of
self-publishing that's happened today I
mean I confess I cruise sometimes the
internet and you find what housewives
with a video cam that are making money
hahaha
hey thank you thank you very much for
sharing I'll see you afterwards and IRA
Smith could you speak to that in
particular and the idea that yeah
actually I want to come back on this
idea that porn is representing real sex
and somehow we're responsible for that I
would say pornographers aren't
responsible for that I think it would be
just as unreasonable to go to a comedic
director and say to them it's unfair
you're making life look much more funny
than it really is and therefore
therefore when I look at my own life I'm
depressed and that's your fault I think
that's really unfair we're not saying
it's real sex we're saying it's a
performance actually I think it would be
ethically dubious if it were real sex
because it'd be voyeurism and it would
be somehow you know I want to know the
performers that definitely know they're
performing somehow I think that's
cleaner but coming back to your put one
point that you made about that I've not
seen that documentary but one thing I've
noticed very much in my industry and
it's only happened a couple of times
when I've had porn stars come back so
when you take my photos off your on my
name off your website or something like
that they never offered to give the
money back it has to be said but but I
always take the name off but and there's
no point taking the photos off because
the images are out there anyway and once
you sign that release form that's one of
the things you must make that decision
you know I know I'll never be a teaching
children it's an important decision to
make
but the thing is that what I what I've
seen about two or three porn stars have
asked me to do that the problem is the
outs they don't regret what they've done
certainly not while they're in the
industry
when they leave it they have problems
for instance getting other jobs or
having access to their children I've
known people who have been denied access
to their children through the divorce
courts for for being in pornography and
then they take on this kind of external
guilt for having done things in
retrospect and yet I know those people
when they were working in the industry
we're loving it and I think that's one
of the problems is we need to naturalize
it so that that people don't have to to
go through that afterwards I think it's
really wrong can I come to you dr.
Lefevre and pick up on the point you
mentioned yourself this idea that porn
destroys lives but to answer the
question without it how do we become
less repressed it's a question of human
values and what we really want what we
believe in
I have no religious belief but I have
very strong spiritual beliefs in
concepts such as honor trust beauty
innocence these are the things that I
think really matter to me for my
children and grandchildren I don't want
them to have to apologize for their
behavior nor do I want them to be proud
of it and that's it's something that
they them deserves acknowledged didn't
help them towards being happier or that
did help them to have a more fulfilling
and creative life what I think we're
missing out on here is a concept of
value what are our values our ethics our
principles these are the things which we
need to look at in order to hand on to
future generations something that's
worthy of them thank you take a few more
brief comments before we go to closing
remarks yes my name is Tessa Grendel two
points one is pornography is good for us
we need to define who us is because we
don't all know what's good for us and
the children especially don't know
what's good for them because they
haven't made up their minds and secondly
at this point is the written written
word and the visual image are supposed
to be both educated and informative and
if doctors aren't informed how can we
expect children to be informed if we're
not teaching them something in schools
thank you to here hi i'm simon against
the motion albeit somewhat
sadly I make for sharing when I when I
was when I was a school not long ago in
fact pornography for me was top shelf
that send a friend in usually taller who
would get it and it
rtl the German channel maybe a little
later and that's somewhat shaped my view
of sex said early on and and I suppose
the point I want to bring in is that
people who are of school age now have
access to Internet where the normal
thing and you've spoken about quite sort
of minority pornography is like gonzo is
is quite it's really hardcore and
unpleasant and I've come across it I've
talked about it with friends of a
similar age we spoke about it last week
and one guy was like well it's affected
the way I now approach sex with women
particularly in brief encounters and I
want to sort of ask do you think that
this type of porn that is everywhere now
that anyone can get to with a click of a
mouse very easily could impact will
impact does impact the psychology and
the attitudes towards sex of young
people and young men in particular thank
you gentlemen behind you
[Applause]
[Music]
I have two questions when I was studying
and was looking at trying to get some
work while to support my studies I
looked at few advertisements on gumtree
for becoming a porn star or whatever and
I didn't see it especially as being
exploited I thought about it but then I
just felt that if the video gets out and
somehow my dad comes to know about it he
won't be particularly very happy about
it so I wanted to ask why do we have and
there was a lot of fear when I really
visualized that the video is out what
everybody knows that I have been in upon
movie and the way people are looking at
me and all the peroneal with it why do
we have this kind of attitude this kind
of stigma towards a sexual act which is
which we wouldn't have been here without
it yeah and my second question is no one
question only one person here please and
then one over here and then we'll go to
the panel I'm Monica rip pornography is
definitely good for us my opinion and I
just want to make the point really it's
not necessary a solitary activity you
can be in a loving relationship and
exploit your desires through pornography
in some way staying within the intimacy
of a loving relationship Thank You
Steven
[Applause]
a building on that point I just wanted
to suggest that it depends on a lot of
things I'm how when and why you're
consuming it an analogy in terms of
addiction may be the difference between
sharing a bottle of wine with your
partner over dinner and drinking the
entire bottle of whiskey down the park
on your own thank you so professor to
main Korea pornography is possible
loving relationship you know one way we
could become a less repressed Society
would be if we stopped privilege in
monogamy lots of people are oppressed
because they've got to take care of
their parent and everybody makes such a
fuss about it when we really know that
human beings are not monogamous and if
we were just a bit more relaxed about it
maybe we wouldn't be quite so repressed
and maybe we could actually recognize
the sexual component in the kinds of
encounters we have outside our core
relationship but we seem to think that
some you could use pornography as a way
of strengthening that relationship and
that would that's okay that's a good
thing see to an anarchist like myself
and the sexual liberation is like myself
that's having everything upside down
thank you I wonder if you could answer
the question about whether exposure to
pornography affects how we approach sex
I think the question was in particular
about young men well I think I think
there are a number of issues that are
tied up there I'd point isn't doesn't
claim for itself a role as a sex
educator but unfortunately it has
acquired that role and some of it
actually can be very good the the idea
that we can see lots of different bodies
lots of different practices lots of
different ways of of dealing with bodies
is good because actually within schools
there is little or no comprehensive sex
and relationship education the problem
is of course that we've got a government
who wants to be seen to be doing
something about young men and there
the ability to view porn online but
isn't prepared to put its money where
its mouth is and to think about how we
might offer sex education healthy sex
education to children throughout their
school years and that would be about how
do we foster intimacy how do we deal
with problems like jealousy between
couples or you know amongst friendship
groups the fact is that you know kids
are very able to understand questions
around jealousy because they feel that
very much as young children playing
around toys doesn't have to be bad sex
but we refuse to actually acknowledge
that there are these very deep and
problematic feelings that young people
may encounter as they grow older and
that some of those will come through sex
and we have sold the past to kids in
terms of giving them decent sex
education the only thing they get is the
berating about it you could get a
sexually transmitted infection you could
get pregnant people will lose respect
for you there is no sense of the ways in
which there might be pleasures in
sexuality that there might be something
really rich and marvelous that would
come to you and that of course that
might be why you might think I'm not
going to wear a condom on this occasion
because you know that would be to break
the mood we we are too much in love with
the idea of of love and without any real
sense of what it might mean to equip our
kids for encountering porn and sex and
I've got to say that gonzo is one of the
most visible genres but it is not the
predominant genre it has to be repeated
because we all forget to take the point
about why we stigma stigmatize porn
stars obviously you work with them on a
daily basis do you feel that they are
stigmatized and well I set up my website
we consent dog because I think also
people that work in the sex industry
whether it's lap dancers sex workers
whatever we are all facing stigma war
facing various backlashes and if you
actually trawl the web
for news every day and you just see it
left right and center we are kind of
divided and ruled and if you actually
bring them all together and you're
getting one story about lap dancing then
what about stiffer and stuff like this
we are guessing it left right and center
and it's all for the same kind of moral
reasoning that sort of sees people that
work in sex industry as I'm going to
talk about it might last minute so I go
on but I would say that's the only way
forward I mean I think the argument
about anti-pornography sits on the what
people most people would know as the
horde Madonna dichotomy it's a pedestal
and women who fulfill certain roles that
are useful for men for instance the good
mother nice wife you know
non-competitive work friend etc I put on
these kind of pedestal pedestals and
when they and when a woman falls off
that for instance for being you know
sexually promiscuous or about a bad
mother almost bad mother as a father is
sometimes and stuff like this you get
hostile sexism and I think the whole
argument about anti pornography is
saying please don't treat us as [ __ ]
because we are Madonna's and I think the
point is that we need to see people that
work in the sex industry as for instance
myself you know I'm a porn director but
I stood for Parliament or I'm doing a
PhD
you've got sex workers who are good
mothers you know good friends people in
porn stars I know are very faithful to
their partners but they work every day
doing porn it's a it's about breaking
that up and saying that women especially
are very mixed and we are both we don't
and briefly dr. Lefevre I wonder if you
could ask the question that's posed and
by the motion when we say us who do we
mean by us who are you thinking of us
when you address the motion today
pornography is good for us is it good
for me I don't know I don't do it is it
good for you I certainly don't know
if you find it's good for you then
believe you but whether it's good for us
as a society is a different matter does
it make us happier I do know from the
medical perspective that the most
significant health factor of all is far
more than giving up smoking leave that
in the shade it's having a long-term
close personal relationship now
the sport love that's pornography helped
that well it appears it it may do in
some people and fine
but does it in general I would doubt it
okay let's ask our panel to give us
their closing remarks L each speak for
two minutes
in reverse order so can I please ask
speaking against the motion for your
closing remarks
professor Germaine Greer ah well here I
am the the ancient pornographer who
doesn't really know what's going on now
even though every time I turn on my TV
it tells me I've got some extra channels
and they always turn out to be composed
of rubbery [ __ ] and shaven [ __ ] that
are and it says that I can press exit
and I don't have to watch it and every
time it's before breakfast and I've got
this extraordinary sausage like writhing
thing happening and I wouldn't worry too
much about your father recognizing you
because in most of them the man's head
isn't in the picture
[Laughter]
and the girls don't have many of very
many shots of their faces and less of
course they're actually chewing on the
penis at the time and then it's quite
hard to recognize them - I mean if if
what we're talking about is the lumpin
McDonald's variety of sexual convenience
food that is what is being dished out
that you can see in your hotel room I
mean I keep being told that I can find
all this special stuff if I spend a long
time on the internet looking for it but
what is actually being beamed at you all
the time is a much more ordinary
McDonald's brand of convenient sex which
doesn't imply anything about personality
or about history or that story or about
tension or anything and it seems to be
simply an aid to masturbation now the
this is the big problem for me that it
teaches you to use bodies as sex aids if
what you've if you've learnt how to
pleasure yourself by watching this kind
of mainstream porn which is the easiest
thing to get hold of but it seems to me
you will fetishize other people's bodies
and you will treat them as sex aids
and you will not be able to incorporate
the person in the body and that you will
end up manipulating your partner as as
if you are masturbating using your
partner's body as an aide and that's
miserable
that's lonely that's not communicating
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking for the motion
dr. Clarissa Smith well I have to I have
to open mind with the question what is
wrong with masturbation I don't know why
we have such a downer on masturbation
it is obviously sex with someone I love
you know I mean I don't myself there are
all kinds of ways in which masturbation
may well be good for us this idea that
somehow masturbation is a problem why
how are we to learn what our bodies like
if we don't engage in masturbation and
following on from that of course is this
idea that we've heard tonight the porn
is a problem because it's wasteful
because it has an ability to take it
over that it's exaggerated feelings and
emotions believe is unprepared for real
life but actually masturbation is a form
of sexual practice a form of sexuality
and for some people for lots of people
pornography is an agenda and an addendum
to their their sexual lives it is not
something that they see as meaningless
purposeless a waste of time but actually
something that engages them emotionally
in fantasy it takes them into other
places it allows them to imagine doing
other things how that might be with
somebody would I like that do I like
that
should I like that because of course
there's plenty of ways in which people
still feel quite oppressed by the idea
of what ought to be normal and what what
isn't there's a real problem it seems to
me with the idea that pornography is
always a symptom of weakness as
self-indulgence or a loss of contact
with your true self and that's not the
picture that comes across when you
actually talk to people about their use
of pornography and I should be clear
here that people don't talk just in
terms of the positives right they also
talk about the negatives that they've
experienced they do self diagnosed as
addicted there is no doubt that some
people have problems with pornography
but to say that that is or
all pornography years it's a real
problem Thanks thank you and speaking
against motion in his closed remarks dr.
Robert Lefevre I want to address the
point made by one of the questioners who
said that because something felt good
you didn't see why it shouldn't be good
or something along those lines well I've
done a lot of that I have years of
active addiction was things that I
thought were just wonderful ah yeah and
they destroyed me the only way that I
got better was because my wife was
sitting in front of a divorce lawyer the
principal because it feels good it is
good is utterly wrong no there are lots
of things I do enjoy I don't go to a lot
of operas my wife and I loved them and
we heard jonas kaufmann at they're all a
festival role on Sunday night
wow what a singer now that was a natural
high but a lot of things were doing in
the pornographic industry or in
addiction generally I'm not saying that
all pornographers for addicts I've made
that point earlier unnatural highs
insofar as they're not something that
spontaneously comes as a result of a
beautiful relationship with something
we're trying to grab at and I don't
think that works thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and finally speaking for the motion and
an Aerosmith I just when it starts on
this sort of separation between the mind
and the body Foucault famously says with
reference to feminism he said tried
saying to athletes huh you're only known
for your body you know there's nothing
wrong with being known for your body and
it you and I think porn stars actually
use them in very useful and they push
boundaries and they do things with them
that are athletic at least and I want to
go into a few anecdotes of people that
I've met I was standing at erotica at
the store and this lady came out and
started talking about my porn and she
didn't know I was an aspen and she said
I used to be absolutely you had high sex
drive but I had a low self-esteem and I
slept with every boy in the school when
I was sort of 1516 years old and I got a
terrible reputation and she said and
then I just assumed that having a sex
drive and being sexually inquisitive was
a bad thing and society said that and
she said then I found Anna spawns porn
and she's sitting there talking without
the third person and she said and she
taught me that you can have sex
good hardcore sex and it can be
respectful that the women aren't treated
badly and then I explained who I was and
she burst into tears and she came two
years later didn't she a completely
changed person she'd gone through loads
of therapy another one a man emailed me
and said that porn I mean he used these
words he said it saved my life he said I
got cancer of the face he said I lost my
job I lost my wife I lost my family and
he said if it wasn't for the fact that I
could liaised with women on on webcams
that couldn't see me because I looked so
horrendous he said I literally would
have had nobody to interact with and I
would have given up my life another case
we're standing at a rhotic er and a
couple came up she was heavily pregnant
and she said hug a hoodie scene 3 she
said to me the pair of them was standing
there I was extremely proud of that and
I just were ending on I want to ask a
couple of questions if we want blaming
the pornography for the falling of
women's right
or you know things like that what else
would be for me focusing on you know
we'd be focusing much more on for
instance gendered representation in
everyday advertising and things like
that but also political representation
and things that really matter and the
last thing I want to say is understand
this that from my work with we consent
org when people attack an industry they
attack the people in that industry it
may sound like a separate it's kind of
abstract thing to you you can have a go
at this big capitalist thing there's
nothing wrong with being in industry we
all work in industries I have no problem
with the porn industry making money or
not making money I never understand why
people suddenly get very anti-capitalist
when they don't against the film
industry for instance but the point is
when you have a go at an industry you
have a go at us because from our
perspective your your your hope your
saying that we are bad people you're
saying where rape mongers or you know
we're setting a bad example or something
so please understand the personal costs
for that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so as the counting goes on feverishly
behind the scenes watch my language
there perhaps we'll go back to the floor
for a few more comments even though they
can't sway anybody now if you have a
burning but brief we've spoken to the
coupon starburns we've answered your
question yes can we have the gentleman
at the back with the beard
I was just wondering given the actually
on there's two panelists on either side
they're wearing gray oppression and I
think I'm right in saying that the
biggest grossing selling book of almost
all time is fifty shades of gray so how
do you explain that if we are repressed
or if we're not and pornography is to
blame I was wondering what the panelists
might think about that one to muse on
another time I'll take one more comment
before I reveal the results a brief
comment from somebody burning speak oh
you want to know the results that badly
no Steven you've had your go okay so
we'll go to the results and let me
remind you of our results Oh would you
like to quickly say something well sadly
best eality on Dartmoor is alive and
kicking and nobody seems to be
addressing the really horrible aspects
of pornography like pedophilia in its
rawest sense and I would have loved to
have asked a question of the Baptist on
that front thank you thank you for
revealing dermals issues so let's remind
ourselves of the results before the
debate took place
you voted 45 percents for the motion 22
percent against the motion 33 percent
undecided after the debate you voted 50
percent for the motion 44 percent
against and only now 6 percent undecided
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
we then have to well I declare the
motion carried is the motions carried at
fifty percent right is that right
okay very very close interesting results
so thank you to all of you for being
such a fantastic process participative
audience but please give a warm round of
applause to all of our panelists for
their fantastic contribution
[Music]
you
[Applause]